US President Donald Trump is turning up
the pressure on Venezuela's Nicolas
Maduro in a television interview this
morning Trump warned that sending troops
into the country is an option pressure
is coming from Europe to France and
Austria have said a game today they'll
endorse self-declared interim president
Juan Guido
if Maduro doesn't call elections before
the end of the day other countries are
expected to do the same in Venezuela
both sides held mass rallies or for more
let's go to our correspondent in Caracas
Oscar Schlenker Oscar thanks for joining
me
u.s. president Donald Trump has said
that sending military to Venezuela was
now an option how will that go down with
the Maduro camp well we have seen that
Maduro has been leading military
exercise exercises in the past week he
has vowed to strengthen militia that
support his government other leaders in
my boudreaux's government have called
upon their supporters to defend the
country against an imperialist strike
against Venezuela
now the opposition has seen this as a
show of power in front of the nation to
demonstrate Maduro has control over the
military because in the past year we
have seen small revolts from the
military against Maduro and yesterday a
division general and Venezuela's
aviation deflected against what he
called a dictatorship we saw later other
active members follow suit so what could
happen if there is an American military
intervention depends on how strong
maneuvers grasp of the military actually
is because if what we saw yesterday from
some of the military continues this
could lead to a domino effect that could
ask menudo in the following days
otherwise we could see clashes which is
something nobody knows
US intervention would be good news for
one quite oh why doe and his supporters
now wouldn't it well from where those
camp we have heard little about their
support for an outside intervention
other than the humanitarian aid for food
and medicines he is asking the u.s. to
send to Venezuela why though has asked
the Venezuelan military to allow this
humanitarian
to enter Venezuela and fight against
Colombia gorillas that have control of
some areas in Venezuela that are needed
to allow access in order to distribute
this aid he also said that there will be
gathering centers in Colombia and Brazil
now we have seen in social media videos
of tanks and military heading to the
border of Venezuela raising people's
alarm about military intervention or a
corridor to allow a to enter Venezuela
we've also heard rumors that if there is
a military intervention in Venezuela it
would be led by Venezuelan military that
are in exile officers that love the
country and deflected because of their
opposition to Nicolas Maduro we have
seen several videos of this of these
military in the past week from exiled
Venezuelan military pledge and support
for one way though but as I said these
are rumors and it all depends on how
strong Maduro can hold the support of
his ranks what does this latest
development mean for the bigger picture
in Venezuela well anything can happen in
Venezuela but we have seen that the
country has become the discord sample
between Russia and the US and now with
both countries dropping the INF nuclear
treaty there are fears of a new cold war
arising with Venezuela acting as a new
Cuba obviously that's something nobody
wants and there's a lot of people
putting hope in that one way though can
regain power of the country in the in
the constitutional way and not through
means of force DW correspondent Oscar
Schlenker in Caracas thank you